hey there crazies in our video about the
universe being a big simulation we said
this what about Punk time and John John
he was wondering what the heck plunk
units were first things first what are
units units are really important we can
sit and theorize all day but eventually
we're gonna have to take some
measurements in the real world and that
demands a unit which can really be
anything as we saw in our faking gravity
video this is about five football fields
for three and a half Giza pyramids or
110 Volkswagen Jettas or 733 Juba socks
it doesn't matter what the unit is just
that we all agree and understand what it
is otherwise you end up with a Mars
Polar Lander crashing into Mars because
someone didn't do a unit conversion
seriously links in the doobly-doo
actually it matters little the metric
system is based on 10 which is
significant easier using the imperial
system you the United States uh so
here's the problem what if you wanted to
communicate the average height of a
human being
to an alien race yes Milton like you
they're not going to understand football
fields or tube socks or any abstract
units like miles or meters you need
something you know that they are
familiar with we call these types of
units natural units because they're
based on nature they're supposed to be
independent of our subjectivity you know
that stuff we impose on almost
everything for example I could measure
my height in ground state hydrogen atoms
all of which are identically 1/10 of a
nanometer tall we sometimes call that an
angstrom after the Swedish physicist
that would make me about 18 billion
hydrogen atoms tall it's pretty average
for a human this is kind of what Planck
units are but instead of being based on
ideas like atoms they're based on the
fundamental constants of nature the
gravitational constant which dictates
the influence of gravity Clark's
constant which determines how lumpy and
uncertain the quantum world is the speed
of light which is how quickly different
parts of space-time can communicate ooh
mom's constant which governs electricity
and Boltzmann's constant which controls
the statistical behavior of large
systems of particles we're pretty sure
they're the same everywhere in the
universe but again aliens are going to
have their own units and if they have
different numbers of these they're
probably not going to be using base 10
math either to make these more universal
we're going to need to do something
crazy just for the sake of argument
let's set all of these equal to 1 the
number 1 exists in all base systems and
there are no more units wait how can you
just do that
well you can't unless you change
everything else to changing those
constants to 1 changes the unit's we use
for length time mass charge temperature
and frankly any units based on those
area volume force energy power momentum
frequency the list goes on every single
one of those is now measured in
something we call a plunk unit named for
the German physicist max Karl Ernst
Ludwig thunk or just max plunk for short
who invented most of them back in 1900
seee
historically understanding physical
quantities starts with length so it was
very natural for plot to do the same
with his units plunk length is about 10
to the negative thirty fifth meters to
understand how small this is we need to
turn back the clock a little to the time
machine
playing the expanding universe in
Reverse we can look way back in time at
one point the universe was the size of a
basketball and then a human egg cell and
then an atom and then a proton at 10 to
the negative 18 meters we reach the
smallest distance we've ever measured at
the making of this video
clunk length is 17 more decimal places
it's insane when the universe was this
small we call that the planck era it was
1 Planck length across 1 plunk time old
and one plot temperature hot which is
really hot ok let's get back to the lab
what's so special about plunk 'hlink
nothing really at least not yet some
models of quantum gravity say that plunk
length is the smallest possible distance
because quantum mechanics loves it when
things are quantized like that but
remember we've only been able to measure
down to about 10 to the negative 18
meters so we're really not sure about
anything smaller and no model of quantum
gravity has any experimental
anyway even if space does have a
smallest amount of chunk or whatever it
could just as easily be a tenth of a
plunk length or a thousand times a block
length as long as it's less than ten to
the negative 18 meters what I find
interesting is how ordinary some of the
other plunk units are plunk mass is
about the mass of a flea egg clunk
energy is about what you could get out
of a 16 gallon tank of gasoline plunk
resistance is about 30 ohms which is a
resistor I use all the time you got to
admit it's kind of cool so do you think
plug units have any physical
significance let's continue this
conversation in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video please
subscribe if you'd like to see more
science like this and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
in the last video a clone fell into a
black hole
come on response time Amit Patel was
wondering why larger black holes don't
spaghettify you like smaller ones do an
event horizon is an event horizon right
yes an event horizon is always a point
of infinite time dilation and yes bigger
black holes have stronger gravity but
that's okay because the strength of
gravity is not what rips you apart
it's the difference in strength between
say your head and your feet those
differences are bigger around smaller
black holes
even though overall those holes are
weaker Kamikaze cateura and david CH
asked what the rest of the universe
would look like to the expendable clone
as he fell into the black hole at first
I thought the entire future of the
universe would pass before his eyes but
that's actually not the case
even though the rest of the universe
does speed up from his point of view it
doesn't speed up enough for him to see
the end of the universe the last light
he sees is not the last light that
arrives at the horizon infinity is so
weird Johan was thinking maybe the event
horizon and the singularity are
equivalent mathematically that's not
that far off a singularity is just a
place where an equation blows up to
infinity the black hole singularity is
what you call a physical singularity
it's there no matter what your point of
view is the event horizon is what you
call a coordinate singularity it's there
in one set of coordinates like the ones
I'd use on my space station watching in
a safe distance but not another set of
like the ones my clone would use as he's
falling into the black hole so they're
very similar mathematically physically
they're very different things if you're
looking for a more thorough conversation
about how Hawking radiation might affect
the fall into the black hole the comment
thread started by David two one six
eight six is a good place to start
otherwise you'll have to wait until my
video on the black hole information
paradox is ready it's tough stuff so
it's taking a while and finally your
master seems to want to start a clone
Union to protect all my clothes from all
the science we do here that's no fun I'm
not entirely sure I feel about this but
good luck getting them to organize I
have a hard enough time with it and
they're my clothes anyway as usual links
to all the comments in the doobly-doo
and thanks for watching